[Musique]
nous sommes le 17 janvier 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 invités émission dédiée à celles et
ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département voici lé titre elle les
sables d'olonne dans le viseur les
participants du vendée globe touche au
but après plus de soixante douze jours
en mer une aventure en solitaire mais
dans laquelle la famille a son rôle à
jouer comment vit-elle justement à ces
familles ce tour du monde
réponse avec jon burton c'est la mère de
louis burton originaire de rambouillet
elle est actuellement 7e au classement
général et puis bientôt une monnaie à
locale en vallée de chevreuse c'est en
tout cas le souhait de stéphane immergée
de marque l'a lu elles se seront à nos
deux prochains invités qui nous
rejoindront dans une poignée de minutes
sur ce plateau
on va commencer cette émission donc par
le vendée globe cette course au large en
solitaire sans escale sans assistance au
tour au stand pardon autour du monde qui
existe depuis 1989 pour les monocoques
de 60 pieds l'édition 2016 la huitième
édition a été lancée en novembre dernier
après plus de soixante douze jours armel
le cléac'h et alex thomson figure en
tête ils se disputent la gagne et votre
fils jaime burton est en 7e position
bonsoir sur ce plateau est ce que vous
avez eu récemment des nouvelles de lui
porter ce matin il indique qu'il allait
m'appeler vous êtes régulièrement en
contact avec lui comment vous vivez vous
sur la terre ferme cette compétition oui
écouter c c sont aventurés
et je la respecte fondamentalement c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on peut discuter par
mail essentiellement moi je téléphone
jamais parce qu'on ne sait jamais à quel
moment on arrive et puis le coup de
téléphone arrive ça peut vraiment être
perturbant donc voilà mais c'est lui qui
appelle et son état d'esprit il est
plutôt satisfait de sa performance
jusqu'à maintenant il avait dû
abandonner lors de la précédente
participation il était le benjamin là il
a forcément un peu plus d'expérience il
est satisfaite de son périple jusqu'à
présent et je crois puis je crois que
c'est une aventure il le dit lui-même
aussi intérieure et puis il rencontre
des conditions qui sont très variables
d'un coin de la planète à l'autre
évidemment et pour l'instant ça passe
malgré certaines difficultés il semble
c'est ce que tout le monde dit maîtriser
une course lui maîtrisé son affaire
donc lors de sa précédente participation
que je l'évoquais il adieu abandonniez
abandonné parce qu'il avait percuté un
chalutier au large du portugal est cette
compétition cette course c'est aussi un
moment d'angoissé non pour les familles
oui il ya des inquiétudes mais bien sûr
vous arriver à dormir la nuit
c'est vrai mais toujours il ya des mots
qu'on veut qu'on commence plus mais non
bien sûr mais en même temps il ya une
contradiction entre avoir peur et ne pas
lui faire confiance
vous voyez ce que je veux dire à partir
du moment où je lui fais confiance je
peux pas avoir peur
donc je lui fais confiance je sais qu'il
va y arriver il est parti dans un
excellent état d'esprit
et puis il a beaucoup d'humour et donc
bon voilà il est originaire de
rambouillet il a commencé à grandir dans
département des yvelines est ce que tout
petit déjà il a commencé justement un
peu à vouloir s'initier à la navigation
ça a commencé
oui parce qu'on on est
une famille enfin on était à l'époque où
il était petit et puis après une famille
de petits navigateurs voiliers de
navigateurs du dimanche donc c'est vrai
que on a toujours fait du bateau avec
les enfants depuis
même quand il était pas tout à fait né
par exemple et donc ça vous allez lui
c'est un bon il a du talent c'est un
c'est quelque chose d'assez particulier
parce que même tout petit on sentait
parfaitement que quand il prenait le
bateau le bateau se calme et que ils
prenaient davantage le vent ça moi
jamais je considère que c'est un talent
voyez comme un grand musicien ou comme
quelqu un bon qu'à quelque chose par
rapport à par rapport à ça explique
aussi peut-être que vous soyez rassurés
lorsqu'il part en mer puisque vous
l'avez vu évoluer vous êtes à même de
connaître ses compétences et ses
capacités
quand il a décidé justement de se lancer
dans la navigation vous l'avait
encouragé comme on vous l'avait
accompagné la question mais c'était une
sorte de ciel qui vous tombe sur la tête
il a fallu digérer la nouvelle déjà dans
un premier temps c'est un peu ça voilà
et puis et puis commencer le commencer
l'aventuré avec peu de moyens avec peu
d'expérience et ce qui est
extraordinaire dans son aventure c'est
que dès sa première course il a été
soutenu par bureau vallée et il l'est
toujours
donc voyez il ya des grande fidélité
comme ça qui sont alors c'est un peu
devenu commun de dire que finalement
louis a agrandi avec bureau vallée mais
c'est vrai qu'il a permis justement et
qui lui permet encore de naviguer on en
voit les images justement de de son
monocoque qui qui fait actuellement donc
cette cette compétition se vendaient et
globe sont son retour ce sera à peu près
quand vous avez une idée on est à 72
jour là il ne figure pas dans le dans le
peloton de tête mais est à la septième
place tout de même alors les îles et à
la 7e place mais
vous savez dans cette course il y a des
bateaux très récent il ya des bateaux
anciens et lui fait partie des bateaux
anciens et donc je crois qu'il est à je
ne sais pas dire en premier mais des
bateaux anciens mais bon je page pas
trés trés spécialistes mais enfin dans
les bateaux anciens où il est très bien
placé et puis la course fait des
estimations
donc dès qu'on parle d'arrivée
d'estimation on a tendance un peu à
croiser les doigts n'est ce pas donc on
va pas juriez l'avenir mêlée les
premières estimations sont 28 29 ou 30
janvier et vous serez présente à bas
bien voir accueillir un bain bien sûr
c'est difficile d'être une dernière
question est-ce que c'est difficile
aussi de de le laisser revenir qu'il
s'acclimate à nouveau à la vie sur sur
la terre ferme là il est isolé lorsqu'il
revient il ya toujours un moment
d'adaptation petit peu je crois je crois
que c'est ça fait partie aussi de ceux
de cette aventure et je crois que de
nouveaux le contact avec la réalité
vous savez quand on ils ont vécu ce
qu'ils ont vécu
ils sont un côté un peu invincible tout
est possible il ya un côté comme ça chez
tous ces grands marins en solitaire ils
ont un côté en effet tout à fait tout
est possible puisque voilà donc un
moment donné bon il faut revenir à la
réalité mais lou est très entouré il a
une famille qui l'adorent et ce sera
probablement sa joie de les retrouver
pour son retour qui sera à la fin de ce
mois de janvier bien évidemment nous
reviendrons sur ces différents résultats
dans nos différentes éditions merci
beaucoup
jeanne burton des 13e nous voir en
plateau
nous allons à présent parler d'une toute
autre aventure le lancement d'une
monnaie locale en vallée de chevreuse
stéphane immergez vous êtes membre du
comité d'animation de la monnaie locale
en vallée de chevreuse et marque la vue
vous en êtes le référent prospection
soir à tous les deux est depuis un an
vous travaillez sur cette idée sur ce
concept
pourquoi tout simplement avoir décidé de
mettre en place une monnaie locale en
vallée de chevreuse alors une monnaie
locale en vallée de chevreuse ça
correspond à un désir de rôles
localisation de 12h à
voilà une famille échanges 100 euros en
monnaie locale elle et assuré que ces
100 heureux vont profiter à tous les
circuits commerçants artisans
producteurs locaux
c'est une monnaie locale et c'est pas
une monnaie avec laquelle on peut
spéculer donc forcément c'est que ça
favorise les échanges et par là même on
retrouve la qualité première de la
monnaie une monnaie qui serait pas
dévoyée par des investissements
hasardeux par des spéculations qui ne
profite pas aux aux habitants donc c'est
vraiment cette nouvelle valeur de la
monnaie qu'on recherche
alors ça concernerait le sud yvelines la
vallée de chevreuse l'ouest de l'essonne
aussi c'est assez large le projet
comment ça fonctionne l'arrêt
concrètement comme ça va fonctionner
écoutez c'est très simple je veux dire
une fois que les commerçants et les
particuliers ont manifesté leur intérêt
de participer à la monnaie qu'ils ont
signé la charte puisqu'il ya un
engagement qui est assignée au départ eh
bien il va et chants ils vont échanger
de d euros contre la monnaie locale pour
une valeur normale mans 2-1 pour ans et
ensuite ils pourront dépenser dans les
réseaux de commerçants qui accepteront
cette monnaie leur argent exactement
comme on le fait avec nos billets
aujourd'hui sauf que ils sauront que
quand il dépense cet argent là il
restera et bénéficiera à l'économie
locale et à la vie locale qu'on
comprenne bien comment ça va bénéficier
à la vie locale
pourquoi ça va être utile à la vie
locale au commerce local est assez
simple ça à comprendre même si c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on n'est pas
habitué en termes de réflexion mais
globalement aujourd'hui quand vous
dépensez un euro dans un commerce
il finit à la banque quand il finit à la
banque il est aspiré par les circuits
financiers et 80% de ce qu'on y dépose
repart au national à l'international et
remonte jusqu'aux grandes institutions
financières ou très grandes entreprises
et 20% continuent à circuler en local
seulement 20% là comme cette mode mais
n'est valable que localement et bien
100% de cette monnaie continuera à
circuler sur le local et à améliorer
accéléré favoriser les échanges
localement et donc l'activité une vie
économique et la vie sociale locale
ça veut dire que c'est une monnaie qui
est en concurrence directe avec leur
traditionnel non pas directement de teuf
cohabiter les deux coffres ou avoir dit
quoi et puis c'est une vraie monnaie qui
est adossé à l'euro qui donc ça donne
toute la gare entier toute la valeur de
la monnaie locale
on met une contrepartie en euros dans
une banque qui ne bouge pas donc on est
véritablement dans une vraie monnaie
mais qui n'a qu'une valeur des changes
et qui n'a absolument pas de valeur
spéculative et avec des visées précises
c'est vraiment la charte qui va définir
tout ça est pour l'instant on est en
travail
on a encore un an pour définir les
choses mais il ya déjà des grands axes
qui se définissent et on sait qu'on veut
viser la production locale
de manière générale les commerces locaux
la production issue de l'agriculture
biologique en particulier et tout ça ça
joue vraiment c'est en fonction de notre
territoire très important parce qu'on a
une complémentarité encore ville
campagne dans cette région nous sommes
qui est importante et on veut continuer
de pouvoir jouer cette complémentarité
et ça veut dire que on va par ce biais
là préservées des paysages on va aussi
donner une valeur sociale à cet argent
qui va pouvoir servir à verser des
prestations à être donc aller en
direction de services très précis et la
dimension sociale et citoyenne est aussi
très important ça ne c'est pas une
initiative isolée de village gaulois on
va dire il ya déjà eu plusieurs
expériences en france une cinquantaine
quel bilan a été fait sur ses
expériences
alors ça fonctionne bilan est assez
diversifié puisqu'il y à des endroits où
ça fonctionne très très bien notamment
quand s'est adossé à une culture à des
valeurs à une cohésion dans le dans la
zone dans laquelle cette monnaie circule
et d'autres endroits où maps
il ya eu des retours arrière et des
annulations ces monnaies ont été à un
moment donné retirer des marchés là les
professionnels quand vous sentez un
petit peu le bassin depuis un an
réagissent comment alors pour l'instant
on les a sont des cas titre voilà deux
de prise d'information par rapport à
comment ils voient les choses mais là on
rentre maintenant dans cette phase où on
va aller prospecter vraiment et leur
dire voilà cette monnaie va démarrer
dans un an
est-ce que vous en serez est ce que vous
ferez partie et les toutes premières
réactions sont soit très favorables soit
au contraire assez
assez distante on a les deux types de
réactions mais on a d'ores et déjà des
gens qui nous dit oui nous on attend ça
pour éventuellement le mettre en place
dans un an c'est le calendrier un peu
qu'est fixée qu'est ce qui manque
à part ça qu'est-ce qui va décider de la
date de lancement les retours des
confessions aspects contractuels à
définir relation avec un imprimeur on va
imprimer des billets qui ne sont pas
n'importe quel biais qui sont ça fait
aussi fiable etc
on a un site internet qui est en cours
de construction on a un nom trouvé un
monde pour cette monnaie aussi ah oui
c'est bien c'est un vrai acte de
naissance il ya possibilité pour tout un
chacun devriez un site internet vélo
n'est vallée de chevreuse y point fr
l'adresse qui va qui va s'afficher parce
qu'on ne voit pas forcément la fiche
mais un site internet pour donner le
pour donner le nom j'ai envie d'ajouter
que je crois que notre monnaie locale
elle aura toute chance de vraiment
prendre corps si on sait vraiment qui on
est et si on arrive vraiment voilà on se
connaissant nous mêmes on sera en mesure
de définir tous les critères qui font
cette monnaie sera très adapté pour
notre territoire
très bien merci à vous d'être venu nous
en parler puis on suivra un petit peu
les différentes étapes avant l'éventuel
lancement d'en annoncer le calendrier
qui est fixée en tout 48 oui merci à
vous deux qui vient c'est la fin de ce
set 8 les invités les programmes qui se
poursuivent sur notre antenne à bientôt
[Musique]